hey everyone this is Jared one of the
creators here at wisecrack with halo 5
now on the shelves we thought there's no
better time to explore some of the more
interesting things happening under the
surface of this blockbuster franchise so
without further ado welcome to this
episode on identity and religion in halo
who is Master Chief with more than 65
million game titles sold it's kind of
crazy that this question still remains
an enigma but it's sort of the reason to
play the game beyond blowing up aliens
and riding around in warthogs Master
Chief is often regarded as one of the
top rated video game characters of all
time but how is that possible if we know
so little about United Nations Space
Command Master Chief Petty Officer
john-117 I suppose the problem starts
with a much more complicated issue
identity itself one's identity is never
cut and dry or easily understandable
identity is always messy unclear and
ambiguous not only is Master Chief's
identity mysterious because we never see
his face there's more his name is
essentially a rank and number and also
because he isn't really alone in all
that armor Master Chief's AI Cortana is
your guide through the Halo universe she
progresses Jon through the game explains
most of the storyline and is also a sort
of quasi lover for the chief come on
chief
take a girlfriend right it might be
possible to read halo as a feminist text
by discussing the hybrid space created
by John and Cortana cyborgs existence a
la Donna Haraway and her cyborg
manifesto yes that's a real thing go
look it up but halo 4 pretty much shits
all over this possibility when the
message essentially becomes cortana is a
damsel in distress who as a woman
shouldn't think too much because well
that's dangerous literally Cortana's
rampancy causes her to think herself to
death but i guess the important thing is
that everything is resolved because she
serves her man well Cortana's entire
storyline is redeemed by getting to
touch the chief just once
something about men in uniform am i
right perhaps identity in halo can be
best understood through the lens of
American political scientist and
philosopher William Connelly
he describes identity formation as a
process of becoming where a person is
taught and chooses how they wish to be
through an encounter with difference
essentially people not only define
themselves by copying what is deemed
cool or acceptable but also by
distancing themselves from things deemed
unacceptable by society it is through
this process of differentiating that
people formed communities and
self-identify whether it be as a mother
son queer garbage man white soldier
writer gamer etc which brings us to the
essential aspect that permeates the
narrative of Halo as well as the second
section of this video
fear of the unknown or as fancy
philosophers like to say fear of the
other it's important to remember the
historical context surrounding halo
premiering in November 2001 it would
perhaps be naive to assume the game is
free of the ideological politics of the
time coming directly after the 9/11
attacks
halo mirrors several elements of the
current war on terrorism I mean for one
the arbiter a disgraced warrior is
promised forgiveness and eternal
salvation if he accepts a suicide
mission no elaboration necessary whether
it's something like the radical Islam at
the center of the World Trade Center
attacks or the fanaticism that motivated
the Oklahoma City bombing at the heart
of terrorism is fundamentalism or the
belief that a particular creed or
conviction is objectively correct and
worth dying or killing for it doesn't
take too much digging to draw parallels
between the Covenant and fundamentalism
a highly religious people guided by the
teaching of three prophets truth mercy
and regret the Covenant are positioned
as the game's antagonist sort of cosmic
religious terrorists religious dogmatism
is essentially the guiding force behind
the conflict in the games the term
covenant itself is a reference to the
pact between a chosen people and their
God the seven halo rings are allusions
to the seven seals of the Apocalypse and
the seven trumpet blasts that bring
about the end of the world the Ark is a
key component to activating the halo
rings which is in part a reference to
the covenant between Noah and God as a
way to survive the great flood
knowing that the flood was an
unstoppable force the forerunners
created the arc in the halo rings as a
way to survive the flood get it the arc
is how you survive the flood captain
Keyes serves as a sort of John the
Baptist baptizing the master chief by
giving him his first gun and also like
John the Baptist Keyes loses his head
consider also the name were given for
Master Chief is John 117 in the King
James Bible John book 1 verse 17 reads
for the law was given by Moses but grace
and truth came by Jesus Christ just as
Jesus gives force to the law with his
eternal grace Master chief gives force
to law with his severely overpowered
pistol kill frenzy given the multiple
times that Master Chief is resurrected
at the end of each Halo game it's not
too much of a stretch to draw the
comparison between Master Chief and the
big JC yes it doesn't take a philosophy
major to see the religious undertones
and all of this the Covenant warship the
forerunners an ancient alien race that
constructed the halo rings the Covenant
believe these rings were constructed for
them as the chosen people or reclaimers
of the forerunners mantle only by
activating the rings while their people
achieve eternal salvation with humanity
the Covenant are confronted with a race
of people that make a similar claim to
ascension and access to the divine when
confronted with an ideology in direct
opposition to their own there are a few
options the Covenant can accept that
there are multiple claims to the truth
or they can exterminate any threats to
their faith Connelly uses the term
exclusive humanism to describe the
belief that people have when they assert
that they have the god market cornered
and everybody else can literally go to
hell the interplanetary war in Halo
starts with an attack on a human colony
planet called harvest where the Covenant
attackers proclaim your destruction is
the will of the gods and we are their
instrument promised the great journey by
the Covenant prophets the Covenant
elites brutes jackals and other mobs
fall into line and start blowing [ __ ] up
it turns out it isn't so much salvation
as it is a cosmic death trap but that's
neither here nor there when you take
into account be clearly deliberate names
harvest and the great journey all this
starts to sound less like religious
fundamentalism and more like manifest
destiny or the idea behind the
civilizing missions of the early
colonial America
harvest is reminiscent of the early
colony life the harvest of crops
Thanksgiving and the pilgrims that
originally came to America are all part
of this sort of storybook version of
American settlement that we were taught
in grade school when in reality was
anything but a great journey or a
children's tale the great journey is
salvation promised only for the advanced
for the covenant the human race is
primitive and can't ascend they aren't
promised salvation this language of
primitivism versus the rational or
civilized goes all the way back to
Descartes basically it's easier to
subjugate an entire population when they
are reduced to a status less than human
as inferior similar to the dynamic
between the humans and the Covenant the
construction of American sovereignty of
national identity creation comes partly
from the displacement assimilation and
eradication of the native cultures of
North America stripping of land rights
from the natives was justified in part
through the dehumanization of their
people they were uncivilized savages
primitives brutes heathens not people
the major event that frames halo is the
fall of reach a human colony laid to
waste by the Covenant by following a
UNSC ship called the Iroquois the
Covenant are able to find reach Iroquois
ought to sound familiar it's a Native
American nation that was part of the
Seven Years War or the French and Indian
War to Americans there's some irony here
in naming a ship intended to facilitate
space colonization after an indigenous
nation in fact a kind of strange
historical reversal takes place the UNSC
with their space marines serve as a sort
of extension of American colonialism and
yet the very same fleet positions itself
as the colonized victim of the Covenant
if as Connelly says identity is
constructed through differentiating
ourselves from others than mixing
imagery from religious extremism and
manifest destiny is perhaps the peak of
irony for the creators for the other
mnestheus fears in religious
specifically Islamic fundamentalism is
not only embodied in the Covenant but
also in our very own history of
colonization
the idea that there would be a game
where you're forced to kill innocence
where the enemy is a blameless victim
probably wouldn't sell many units or
maybe it would
while the first-person shooter genre
inevitably creates shallow characters to
be eliminated disintegrated and
eradicated what halo presents is the
exploration that the enemy the alien the
other is not so different than we
pretend hey everyone thanks so much for
watching if you're interested in more
halo videos then click here to check out
our friends at honest game trailers they
just released their trailer of the Halo
franchise which is really hilarious so
be sure to check it out and subscribe
while you're over there
here wisecrack we've got tons of great
breakdowns coming down the pipeline
likewise for fallout breaking Morty No
Country for Old Men and all five seasons
of Breaking Bad click here to go to our
channel page and watch some more of our
videos and definitely click that
subscribe button so you won't miss any
new ones all right thanks for watching
guys I'm gonna go finish the fallout
video peace
[Music]